questa roba che state per vedere io ve
lo giuro doveva essere tra i primi video
del canale quindi vi parlo di quasi 45
anni fa e poi mi sono completamente
dimenticato di farlo e mi sono ricordato
stamattina doveva fare questo video
gameplay siamo in ritardo di un po però
lo facciamo
ecco perché siamo arrestato perché butto
giù i microfoni signore e signori siamo
su falsa non so come può essere definita
sta roba ma al tempo su youtube andava
un botto brasile i tre ragazzi bisogna
scegliere un nome all'inizio mettiamo
caso jasper jasper mi sembra figo mai
perfetto allora vi spiego come in cosa
consiste questi due amici mi hanno
invitato a casa loro che sarebbe questo
nella casa e belle bella grafica questa
stagione e niente io posso interagire
con loro e posso scriverli proprio le
cose tipo ciao però ovviamente dovrò
scrivere
ok lo schieri in inglese perché tu
giochi d'immenso great to see you anche
per via vai a prendere grace che grace
sarebbe la ditta a steyr aspetta aspetta
questa è casa tua che bella zio porca
vacca che belli muri neri ha un non so
che di di allegro ti svegli contento la
mattina o che bello che siete sposati
your woman il suo sexy basta venite qua
basta litigare venite il coraggio l'uomo
ha riso sex.com tir guys heimat ending
affigga ecco e fatte salve e a spies
sì nukem ex yes week end sono quasi una
simpatica la stessa ironia che uso
condiviso
pensate voi che tenga pure 4 milioni
d'iscritti crazy crazy sto gas che mi ha
avuti test ok
devo seguirlo a casa mi devi far vedere
0 ok ok
un quadro quello deciditi per oddio mica
dica quanti specie making cosa mi dice
questo dipinto catafratto none
catafratto omen nomen omen sibariti che
romance
non ho ben capito il senso di stampa
perché tuo marito è fissato qui quadri
questo è clapis porca vacca subalterno
vado io rispondo io rispondo io zitto
zitto faccio io non sto salvetti salve
incarichi mia figlia strada zitta che
parlo io so we are about to being sexy
come non ho i think we want sex
mi piace questo ragazzo i'm sorry that
we have da fare now quindi quindi come
l'attacco martini sono tele pieni di
telefono che devo testa buttato telefono
stop liti gate end che questa è la
struttura a rete ed ai red herring
vediamo capaci nei sei but i'm back home
versare un po se va bene allora vi sto
cazzo di vedere ma basta basta parlare
che venerdì baby baby ho fatto una cosa
che non sorride in italy wii e ds people
to be in serie a e d one
guys ai go on ice fish eye proprio ai
mid dubbio proprio now prova ben più
litio ha incassato ok ma ti è piaciuto
let me uscire perché fanno uscire il
meglio ai world tourism ai cose police
grosso stop e litigate terza pista morna
cos'ha scritto quindi gli dà grazie wi
fi
di certo grazie intanto insomma
bottiglia di vino melo su chi cioè lo
chardonnay teste di mici bene bene
dovevo veramente farlo cinque anni fa
poi mi sono dimenticato solo fatto
adesso bene meglio tardi che mai
i cinque anni questi due non hanno mai
smesso di litigare bene così quindi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto spero
che avete imparato come consolare una
coppia io non faccio lo psicologo ma
sicuramente se lo stato d'aiuto 20
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto ha
cosi commentato mi piace anche vari
social card di sky ci clicchiamo
proseguito e ragazzi
[Musica]